[Music]
hey everyone and welcome to lesson one
of the basics of data visualization with
r for ecologists
i'm really excited to get started so
let's go right in we're going to cover
the very basics of creating data
visualizations
using the base r package and that's the
package that comes pre-installed with
r if you've already taken my basics of
our free colleges course
and feel confident with the basics then
you might want to skip this module
but either way i think it should offer a
good refresher
so first let's go ahead and load the
data now for this course we're going to
be using mostly built-in data
using the data function to access a
variety of different data
sets that come built in with r and
that's just to make things a bit easier
so we can get right to visualization
so first we're going to load this data
set called
plant growth and so when we run this
line of code
we get this thing that pops up here in
the environment it says promise when we
click on it or whenever we use this
plant growth data frame
the then this gets converted into the
data frame that it is and
so let's take a look at what these data
look like
so if we scroll up here in the console
we can see that we have one column for
weight
and one column called group and so in
this case
for these data we have a total of 30
data points
and weight represents the dry biomass of
each plant in grams
after it's been collected and dried of
course so if we do
table plant growth
and run that actually we want to do the
do a table of all the different groups
we can see that we have
10 different plants for each of these
treatments but let's say that it turns
out that we have another column in this
data set
on the amount of water that each plant
has received throughout its life
in liters so here are the data
they're already in this file so you
don't have to enter them yourself
and we're just going to add that to this
vector of water
and then add that vector of water as a
new column to the plant growth data set
so great now we have these three columns
to work with
so now for your first plot let's create
a scatter plot to see how plant weight
varies
as a function of how much water the
plants received
and to do that all you have to use is
the plot function
and the first argument is the x
in this case we're going to do plant
growth
and remember the dollar sign is used to
select particular columns so in this
case
water so if we were to run just this we
get the vector of water values
so that's going to be the x-axis the
y-axis is going to be the data frame
plant growth
but this time we're going to select
weight so now we can see
this vector of weights so when we run
this
and there you go we get a scatter plot
with plant weight on the y-axis as we
defined it here and plant water or
excuse me the amount of water that was
given to each plant on the x-axis here
and we get this scatter plot so congrats
this is your first plot
and you can make this plot smaller or
larger by resizing this window
that's the great thing about rstudio is
it just has all this built-in
functionality to help you visualize and
work with data in this way
all right but there's some other ways in
which we can use the plot function
we created this plot using the plot
function and specifying the x and the y
axis but there is another way to use the
plot function that is a bit of a better
practice and it's easier to specify the
x and y
axes by saying y is a function of
x or y and then this
tilde symbol which is above underneath
your escape key usually you have to hold
shift down and then press it it's this
horizontal squiggly line
i think it's called a tilde or a tilde
or something like that either way in r
it represents
is a function of
so you can oops whenever you see that
tilde you can read it as
is a function of so in this case y is a
function of
x and so here we can say the weight of
each plant
is the y-axis so the weight of each
plant is a function
of the amount of water that it received
so to use this with the plot function
all we have to do is plot
plant growth
weight so here notice we're reversing
these because we're doing the y first
as a function of plant and as i'm typing
it you'll see this pops up so you can
just click that to make it a little
faster
so plant weight is a function of the
amount of water that it was that it
received
since if we run this you'll see that
nothing changes here then that's just
because it plotted the exact same thing
over again it's just another way of
using the plot function
but this type of notation is really
helpful because we can actually add an
argument to this function
to indicate where the data come from
so instead of having to continuously
write
plant growth here we can just modify
this by saying
weight is a function of water
and then add an argument for data so
data equals
plant growth so now if we run this again
again you'll see that almost nothing
changes here except
now the x and the y axis are just the
name of the variable
instead of this if we click on this
arrow here we can go to the previous
plot we had
instead of having plant growth dollar
sign weight
we just have weight because that's the
name of the column and
it knows where to get those data from
because we added in this data argument
data equals plant growth great so that's
it for this
intro lesson quick summary we loaded our
data
added another column to the data set
plotted a very simple scatter plot using
the plot function
and i showed you a neater way of using
the plot function
by saying the y-axis is a function of
the x-axis
and then adding in the data argument in
the next few lessons we're going to go
over a bit more about how to plot the
two most common types of plots in
ecology using r's built
in base package and then later we'll
move on to a more advanced plotting
system but for now thanks for watching
hope you enjoyed this
and see you in the next lesson
you